[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture et tout de
suite le sommaire de ce mardi 25
septembre 40 is estampes et 22 artistes
pour refléter la guerre pour sa première
exposition lui en cour s'intéresse au
centenaire de la grande guerre
c'est un rendez vous que les amoureux
yvelinois de la bd ne manqueraient pour
rien au monde plus de sept mille
passionnés rencontreront auteurs et
dessinateurs au château de but pour la
25e édition du festival est un peu de
magie avec laura nbi aurel l'artiste
dessine avec du sable est la conter ses
histoires à la merise de trappes le
week-end dernier 2018 marque la dernière
année du centenaire de la guerre 14-18
et des communes n'attendent pas novembre
pour célébrer le devoir de mémoire à
guyancourt art gravure saint-quentin
propose 46 estampes originales de ses
adhérents
[Musique]
quarante six oeuvres pour autant de
regards depuis trois ans les adhérents
d'art gravure saint quentin pour ça la
guerre alors guerre c'est le ressenti de
chacun c'est le vécu c'est l'émotion
c'est faire ressurgir le passé c'est
eux-mêmes j'allais dire un sujet
d'actualité c'est à dire vraiment
aborder quelque chose de très douloureux
quelquefois de pénibles
[Musique]
le titre d'impression porte bien
justement son nom puisque elle fait
référence à pression fait référence à
l'atelier de gravure nous imprimons nous
passons sous la presse et impressions ce
sont les sentiments les émotions des
graveurs devant la thématique de la
guerre
déjà présenté il ya un an et demi
l'exposition est sans cesse remaniée par
les vingt-deux artistes parfois inspirés
de souvenirs de famille une vingtaine de
nouvelles oeuvres a enrichi la
collection les craver se sont rencontrés
avec les écrits de mérédith le dez qui
était présenté par les itinéraires
poétique et nous avons créé cette
exposition grâce à ses poèmes qu'elle a
pu nous fournir et nous lire même de
l'horreur des tranchées à l'aso
impression de guerre lance la saison
culturelle guyot courtoise très marquée
par le 100e anniversaire de l'armistice
du premier trimestre nous avons voulu le
démarrer avec la thématique du
centenaire et surtout derrière un gros
projet qui a été monté sur le centenaire
pour finir en ce centenaire en 2018 avec
les scolaires elle linogravure aquatinte
pointe sèche
les adhérents ont choisi de représenter
toutes les techniques de la gravure
un travail long et minutieux à l'image
d'un sujet sensible
les petites mains de l'ombre mise en
lumière les archers départementale des
yvelines ont choisi de remercier les
participants à ces divers projets
collaboratifs sur la grande guerre par
une exposition
une vingtaine d'entre eux a été
photographiée partir immouni explication
c'était vraiment mettre une identité
derrière les contributeurs dans notre
travail au quotidien on parle de notre
équipe de contributeurs parce qu'on a
quand même un vivier assez important de
personnes très impliquées très présentes
qui participent beaucoup
et puis finalement comme beaucoup de
projets sont en ligne via des
plateformes informatiques
ce sont des noms des pseudos et on a pas
on les voit pas finalement comme je
m'occupe de mon association
c'est pas toujours facile que les gens
répondent
favorablement à nos attentes donc je
pense que quand on fait un projet c'est
bien d'être disponible pour toutes les
attentes qu'on pourrait avoir derrière
une autre exposition à découvrir depuis
dix huit 18 ans caroline kennerson
questionne le corps ses secrets ses
fragilités elle présente phylogénie
utopique au conservatoire des arts de
montigny le bretonneux
le vernissage est prévu mercredi 26
septembre
maintenant on va parler d'une édition
exceptionnelle les 6 et 7 octobre le
festival de bd de buc fête ses 25 ans
deux jours de rencontres et qu'une
cinquantaine d'auteurs et dessinateurs
un rendez vous qui attire chaque année
plus de 7000 visiteurs et on va en
parler avec nos invités m'ont rejoint en
plateau à nice a terminé la directrice
de la culture de la mairie de buc et
virginie augustin de la dessinatrice
enfin là toutes les deux bonsoir
alors je tourne d'abord vers vous à nice
est admis qui dit anniversaire dit
événement j'imagine et notamment une
fresque qui sera fait en live
absolument donc pour ce 25e anniversaire
il faut savoir qu'un festival pour faire
naître un festival c'est facile mais
pour le faire perdurer
c'est plus difficile donc la ville de
buc effectivement fait les 25 ans d'un
festival bd qui n'a cessé d'évoluer au
fil du temps et qui aujourd'hui
effectivement accueille plus de
cinquante visiteurs 50 de hauteur la
danse de la terminale à 7 mais vu les
visiteurs 8000 et on vise les 10000 pour
le 25ème je l'espère et certains
attendent très tôt on nous disait il ya
2 3 ans et 3 heures voire la veille
avaient passé la nuit sur place et donc
la fiche nous a été faite par alex evra
spirou les grands noms les grands les
grands personnages de bd
tout à fait et puis bien sûr les 25 ans
la municipalité a souhaité marquer le
coup pour pour effectivement fêter ce
quart de siècle
justement est ce qu'il ya des nouveautés
par rapport aux années précédentes
alors il ya des nouveautés c'est de
l'évolution en fait c'est pas vraiment
des nouveautés c'est de l'évolution donc
on a disons que ce festival est d'abord
tout d'abord culturel
il a un volet pédagogique très important
qu'on ne cesse de développer et un volet
aussi patrimoniale j'insiste un peu plus
sur le volet pédagogique et justement
c'est ce qui fait un petit peu le coeur
parce que le festival en lui-même le
coeur du festival c'est l'accueil
d'auteur la rencontre entre le public et
les auteurs des cartes d'auteurs variés
avec une partie dédiée au jeune public
on aime bien aussi le jeune public parce
que c'est aussi un accès à la culture
on défend aussi l'accès à la culture par
la bd et puis un volet pédagogique
extrêmement important pour nous puisque
c'est une manière aussi de fédérer
autour du festival est de pouvoir mettre
en place des animations et des ateliers
à différents niveaux et que ce serait
qu'ils sont entrés notamment dans les
prisons
absolument on a en a dépassé l'aspect au
public ouvert largement les prisons
s'est fait un peu 10 en hiver qu'il
fallait aller
disons qu'on a voulu atteindre cette
fois ce qu'on appelle les publics
empêchés ça a toujours été un rêve du
festival de but que de toucher tous les
publics
donc on a fait un gros travail avec le
public scolaire et cette fois on a visé
le public d'y empêcher
et justement ça a été une très très
belle aventure humaine effectivement
nous sommes allés dans les prisons des
yvelines et trois prisons versailles
bois d'arcy et poissy avec un projet
commun donc vraiment un échange autour
de la bd
nous sommes allés dans un hôpital avec
des enfants très lourdement atteints qui
nous
pas vraiment accès à la culture puisque
leurs pathologies parfois ne le permet
pas le dispositif de traitement est très
très lourd
nous sommes allés vers des adolescents
difficultés et des collégiens oscillera
tous les résultats ce week-end et
notamment le disait 50 dessinateur
scénariste auteur c'est très complet la
bd et on a une avec nous ce soir en
plateau virgin augustin un rendez-vous
comme but que c'est important d'aller à
la rencontre des lecteurs
c'est très important de rencontre des
lecteurs but que je sais enfin
énormément de festivals en france
après on pense qu'il ya à peu près un
festival par week-end à travers toute la
france moi je sais que j'aime bien les
abus que ça fait maintenant quoi toi
trois quatre ans que je viens parce que
c'est pas loin de chez moi et puis
effectivement ça reste un festival très
accessible familiale sympa aussi parce
que moi je retrouve des amis je retrouve
je découvre d'autres personnes que je
connaissais pas enfin je parle des
auteurs bien sûr mais c'est vraiment mon
revers il ya il ya plus de 5300 type ont
été publiés en 2016
et justement vous en mai vous avez un
ouvrage qui est sorti cette deuxième
tome de 40 éléphants mais est-ce que
c'est l'occasion de le faire connaître
aussi même si la houle de septembre
peut-être que les effectivement qu'on
considère que c'est plus une actualité
déjà ça va justement vous parlez du
nombre de sorties
maintenant le marché de la bande
dessinée va très très vite je suis pas
dans la rentrée littéraire maintenant il
ya une rentrée littéraire bande dessinée
effectivement c'est quelque chose de
plus anciens mais mais déjà bon
effectivement la bucs ont fait la
gentillesse de m'inviter
j'ai aussi partie du lait aussi
effectivement pour la participation à
l'atelier ont fait avec les prisons de
ton qu'on évoquait même et donc c'est un
moyen important de défendre un album on
a le soutient effectivement des
libraires je n'arrête pas de dire
effectivement seyrig des libraires et
puis les festivals en fait où justement
on retrouve vraiment le public est
vraiment des femmes des gens qui
viennent de l'eure pour le pour le
travail je parlais de 40 éléphants
vous avez aussi créé alim le tanneur
qu'est ce que les publics pas tout ça
bien sûr parce que d'autres toujours
entouré qu'est ce que le public demande
le plus dessiner est ce qu'il ya un
personnage en partie au fait que ça fait
15 ans à peu près que je fais ce métier
aujourd'hui j'arrive et à suivre affaire
suivre le lectorat sur des nouveautés
pendant très longtemps
alim le tanneur était la série qui
m'était demandé mais d'accord alors on
effectue par le temps malheureusement on
a déjà dépassé notre notre quota mais
pour les 25 ans on oublie pas c'est le 6
et sexe 7 octobre prochain au château de
buc on pourra rencontrer une
cinquantaine d'auteurs dans notre sujet
une table lumineuse une caméra et du
sable trois éléments pour raconter des
rêves lorraine bihorel propos proposé ce
week-end à la merise un spectacle
empreint d'une certaine magie
l'artiste raconte l'histoire et voyages
avec du sable regarder une jolie fleur
en mutation derrière cette main se cache
une jeune artiste lorraine bihorel avec
quelques grains de sable elle vous
entraîne à travers le monde dans des
coupes mouvant ils sont chaque année
d'une manière différente
il y en a qui ont été inspirés
d'histoires que j'aimais bien que j'ai
voulu réinterpréter d'autres ou tout
simplement j'ai fait des essais sur la
sueur sur ma table lumineuse jusqu'à
trouver une idée qui me plaisent
lorraine bihorel découvre la technique à
l'âge de 15 ans et se l'approprient créé
en 2013 des rêves de sable sont des
scènes musicales qui laisse un sentiment
de magie
[Musique]
où
j'avais découvert ça avec le sable mais
aussi juste de voir quelqu'un destinée
j'avais déjà eu l'occasion de voir ça et
à chaque fois je trouve ça assez
fascinant de voir un dessin se
construire sous nos yeux
bah moi tous les dessinateurs ont
l'habitude chez eux de voir le dessin se
construire mais de pouvoir partager ça
avec le public cette voie là il ya
vraiment un côté dessin animé qui nous
replonge en enfance mais à tous les âges
[Musique]
lauren bihorel créé des oeuvres
éphémères avec des gestes envoûtant si
vous avez manqué le spectacle à la
merise l'artiste joue à bois d'arcy le 6
octobre prochain pour des rêves toujours
plus sablé
[Musique]
de la zumba argentine du som nordique
link rue s'affranchit des frontières
dans son dernier album des compositions
qu'elle joue ce vendredi à la batterie
de guyancourt regarder
[Musique]
c'est la fin de ce set 8 culture merci
de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve mardi
prochain
[Musique]